what is going on everybody welcome to
another django with python for web
development tutorial in this tutorial
what we're talking about is the admin
app that comes with your django
applications so the first thing we need
to do if we want to utilize the admin is
as you'll see if we go to our website ok
and you want to go to admin you just do
slash admin and you get here and then
your started thinking hmm what do I do
now admin admin no right so you don't
have an admin you don't know what the
login is so the first thing you have to
do is actually create a super user or an
admin so that's what we're going to do
first so we're going to go and break the
running server and we'll go up here and
get managed up PI and what we want to do
is Python manage PI create super user
hit enter and then now you can define
the user
I'll just call mine admin email address
HS Keynes leage com password whatever
you want it to be I think I picked a
pretty pretty good one okay got our user
and I need to login before I forget the
password so come over here and the
username will be admin oh wait hold on
we need to run the server create super
user so manage up I run server and now
what we want to do is login so you'll
ghost you know your your website slash
admin password good ok so once you've
done that you log in this is the Chango
administration so you'll see here that
you've got groups and you've got users
in here and then what you could do is
you can click on groups for example
there we don't have any groups but you
could like plus add a group and do span
see stuff here and you can go into users
and look at that there we are and we
could set you know are we an active user
if you uncheck this it's basically the
equivalent of deleting an account it
doesn't delete the account but it
doesn't let them
login staff status super user status you
can create custom groups and give very
specific custom user permissions what
can they this user actually do you've
got all this stuff available
okay cool but we don't really care that
much about that what we really want is
well we want a pony right we want to
being able to access our blog table
basically here and edit the blog post
blogs do everything by this
administration panel okay because we
want a pony so what we're going to do is
first we have to admit that we're not
going to get a pony but Jango is going
to give us something close to a pony so
what we're going to do is we're going to
go into blog and you should already have
an admin pie file go ahead and open that
up and you'll see that we're importing
some stuff naturally and then you can
register your models here so what we're
going to do is from blog models import
posts so that's our post class which
defines that table and all that fun
stuff now we're going to do is simple
admin dot sight register and we register
post save that come back to your admin
panel go back to the home boom there's
post oh my goodness so now you can see
that how we got add and change and we
can also click but there's zero posts
but then we can also add a post here so
let's go ahead and add a post
ermahgerd Django is awesome oh wow
okay and then for date what's cool is
you can very quickly just say today
right now and save and add another let's
say stay really December 4 oh my
goodness it's December anyway probably
by the time anybody's seen this will be
even later anyway haha save and you can
either save and continue editing you can
save and add another or you could just
save and we'll save and add another
and then we'll say Amazing Grace today
and now saving add another hello world
good hiya and then we'll do today now
but you can also do like this like you
could say this post was back in
September okay
save alright so now these are our admin
blog and posts so let's go back home and
you would like if you just logged in
admin you'd see this you can click on
posts see like okay cool here's all our
posts hello world and blah blah and you
can edit it you could delete it you
could save and continue editing and
saving add another cool so now what if
we just go to our home page and we click
on blog there's our information right
it's just there and sure enough the
titles are links and in our excitement
we click on one ah it doesn't work why
doesn't it work you ask well of course
we don't have any URL path that explains
or works with slash blog / - we can even
see
well this your slash blog but this is
the home page right it required it to be
slash blog not slash blog - so now what
we have to do is create the handling we
need two URLs we need to view for the
individual posts so that's what we're
gonna be covering in the next tutorial
this one should be quick and easy quick
and painless easy enough for you guys to
get up to this point but if you had any
problems feel free to leave them below
one thing to keep in mind if this is the
first time you visited the admin which
if you're following along it probably
was if it didn't work for whatever
reason you can always go to my site go
to settings and make sure admin is
installed so you'd come down here make
sure you have this line it should be
there by default but if it's not there
for whatever reason you might need to
add that part okay so uh that's that as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support subscriptions until next
time